[Music]
tyler is with us in houston texas hey
tyler how are you
hey dave hey ken how are y'all better
than we deserve what's up
so first off uh before i heard about uh
the whole dave ramsey
um i got a debt consolidation loan
roughly about two years ago
it was for uh ten thousand and i paid
down on it
about seven thousand my question to you
is should i stop
paying on that loan to help pay off
you stop paying you'll be in default why
would you stop paying on it
because it's just hurting the cash flow
that i have
now because right now roughly where me
and my wife are in debt about 51 000 and
majority of that is
cars that we had got um now let me stop
you in a second okay there's a
possibility you're confused
is this a loan you took out or did you
sign up with a debt
consolidation company that's collecting
a payment from you and then working your
debts down yeah well
yeah yeah it's from like lending club
it's a um it was a decade foundation
correct okay you have a you have a you
now have a personal loan for ten
thousand dollars
regardless of why you took the loan out
if you don't pay it they're gonna sue
you
correct you're just gonna go bad on the
loan of course not yourself i'm gonna
tell you to do that
i got you i got you so what would be the
next step into going and paying off
you know i mean getting out 51 000 in
debt and 10 000 of it is this what's the
other 41
uh vehicle loans okay
and what's your household income uh
about a hundred grand a year
and you have forty one thousand dollars
worth of cars yes correct that's a lot
yeah you thought about selling one of
them
yeah we thought about it um but i mean
uh i mean
so i mean we thought about that but that
i mean how would it go about
selling it
uh you put it up for sale it's like
outright selling it
yeah i mean you owe more on it than it's
worth and that's what you mean
well no i mean the i mean the
that what i'm trying to say is like how
do we go about selling i mean do we just
like put a sticker on the throw down the
front yard and just say hey it's for
sale
yeah and you listed on traders uh
traders uh
i would yes all those places list or
whatever you do facebook
places to sell a car you've never sold a
car
i mean yeah i mean also a car but i mean
it's relatively a new car
i mean so i mean i don't know a lot of
people have you know you know eighteen
thousand cash is ready to drop on a
you know a new car you did
yeah so there's lots of people out there
that'll do that they go to the bank get
a loan buy your car from you so you need
to put up
uh the most expensive of the two cars
and get them get it sold
what are the cars it's a 2017 toyota
tacoma and a
uh 2018 uh toyota camry okay
so the taco is probably the expensive
one i'll probably drop the taco
gotcha and here's the thing man uh
you're
the problem is you can't make your
payments and you call me on how not to
make a payment while you have two very
expensive cars sitting in your driveway
because you've got almost a thousand
dollars a month in car payments don't
you
yeah exactly yeah and this is that's
what's killing you
so i'm not against the taco my you know
a couple of my family members have got
them they're pretty that's what we call
them anyway the tacomas are they're
really really good trucks
actually uh toyota makes a good product
but
uh doesn't matter if you can't afford it
and so
pretty simple math transaction here dude
uh the time that you were on the car lot
you said i can i think i can afford this
you were wrong
and so now you're selling it and you're
admitting it
and that gets you some of your cash flow
back and you get a junker to drive until
you get these two
two debts cleaned up the other car and
the ten thousand dollars
and i think you have to uh to work your
way
through this dave this always gets me so
i
i was looking i'm always looking at you
know older cars and things like that
i've kind of just kind of a fun little
thing i like to just see
what's out there you have a great old
car i do have a great old car
carmen geo what year is that thing 1972
yeah the volkswagen carbon gear but
but i was looking around and you'd be
surprised at how many good older toyotas
you take a
a 2003 or 2004 or five camry
you would be surprised at how reliable
they are oh great car and you can go get
those and
that young couple could have two very
reliable cars
for 10 grand or less and i'm not
exaggerating i don't i mean not
exaggerating
daniel ramsey my son drives a taco yeah
um yeah
that thing's gotta be ten years old i'm
driving to 2006.
lexus he doesn't care that has two
hundred thousand miles on it he was
aware of this because i'm a big car guy
and he's not
oddly enough um otherwise he would have
traded out of a 15 year old or
ten-year-old truck or whatever the thing
is but
he's like i don't know what car i would
get that i like better so i'm just
driving it yeah you know and it's
great truck it'll go anywhere it's good
so yeah it's just a matter of what you
can afford and
what you can afford is what you can pay
cash for if you didn't pay cash for it
by definition you can afford it
and that's what we're dealing with